so at some point it was all about
intuition and
nerves also yeah it's so great in that
so i don't think
he should be ashamed of the fact that
he's losing against magnus carlsen with
the black pieces in this way
and do you think you'll regret giving
magnus his like a magnus type of
position or do you think he'll regret
not playing a more active opening maybe
uh i think there was not much
first of all it's very difficult to make
the solution
that that will work against magnus it's
always the case i think that you make a
solution what should i do this or that
and depending on how the game
goes you will regret it or not yeah but
i mean magnus played very well this game
i think
he really felt all the details
and we just see him putting the
finishing touches in white's pawn
marching forward he resigned eventually
very painful loss
but okay this is sport right yeah so
this is how uh
everybody is excited
that the rapport is still keeping his
lead but only very very very tiny half a
point